>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Colleen Shogan: My
name is Colleen Shogan,
I'm director of national
and international outreach
at the Library of Congress and
it's my pleasure to welcome you
to the seventh Annual
National Book Festival.
As you know, the national book
Festival is brought to you
by generous donors and sponsors,
we just want to take a moment
to thank them before we start
particularly our cochair
David Rubenstein.
You too can become
a donor or a sponsor
of the National Book Festival,
the instructions for donations are
in your programs, also on your
phone app and online at LOC.gov.
Before we begin with
just a few announcements
if you have your cell phones please
power them off and at the conclusion
of our program we will be taking
questions from the audience
at one of the microphones.
This afternoon it's really
a distinct pleasure of mine
to be joined on stage
by Dr. Ronald White,
the author of American Ulysses.
Previously, he's written many
books on Abraham Lincoln,
on Lincoln's leadership and also on
Lincoln's rhetoric but today we're
to talk about Ulysses S Grant.
If you haven't read the book
yet I can commend it to you,
it was terrific and it's 827 pages
and I was telling Dr.
White beforehand,
I raced through all 827 pages and
you don't hear that very often.
Given the recent national
conversations about the legacy
of the Civil War, I can't think
of a better person to hear
from this afternoon at the
National Book Festival.
So the kick us off, as I
said about your biography,
you spent years working
on Abraham Lincoln
but most recently you spent
seven years working on Grant.
So can you tell us why the
switch from Lincoln to Grant?
>> Ronald White: I give
my editor the credit,
we were approaching 2011
2015, the 150th commemoration
of the Civil War, you said
you've written on Lincoln,
don't you think Grant
is due for an upgrade?
>> Shogan: There you go, so we're
going to talk about Grant today,
start us out in his early life.
For example, how and why
did he come to West Point?
>> White: Well, first
I wanted to emphasize
that the early life is important
but publishers are rushing
into print biographies but
from my perspective many
of them skip very quickly
over the early years.
I like what Grant says,
he said the reason
that I do not read biographies is
that they do not tell the story
of the boy who becomes the man what
Grant called the formative period
of life.
Think of your own life 16,
18, 20, 22 years of age,
how important that was, so the
traditional biography skipped
over West Point from my
perspective too quickly.
So I spent a week at West
Point, I gave a convocation
at West Point a week ago
Tuesday because I think that was
so important on Grant's life 5'1"
tall, a hundred and 15 pounds,
17 years old he arrives at West
Point and it really is formative
in shaping who he becomes.
>> Shogan: One of the distinctive
contributions in your biography
of Grant is that you focus his
relationship with his wife, Julia.
You quote a lot of their letters
back and forth to each other
and what do you think, what does
that bring to your treatment
of Grant that perhaps other
biographers haven't focused on?
>> White: I came early to believe
that Julia had been minimalized
or marginalized too often that's the
story of women in these biographies.
Julia kept all of Grants letters,
a funny incident was I live
in Southern California
and a friend who's
in the movie industry approached me
and said this would make a
great television miniseries.
So I was all ears and he said
let's get together I said okay.
So tell me some of the most
important things you can
about Grant.
I said I want to tell you about the
marriage between Ulysses and Julia,
what a wonderful marriage and
then I noticed a frown on his face
and he said that will never do, that
never do and I said, what you mean?
He said well it's all based on
internal tension, I said what, what?
So I sent him the first
few chapters and he said,
don't you see the internal tension?
Grant's family was
strongly antislavery,
Julia's father owned 30 slaves,
Grant's family would not come
to the wedding because he was
marrying into a slaveholding family,
Julia's father gave her four
slaves as a wedding gift.
So young people think it's only the
two of them but Grant had to figure
out how he was going to navigate
a marriage with a father-in-law
who had such different views in his
own but at the end of their life
in the White House people would
come upon them now holding hands
like bashful lovers, they did have
one of the great American marriages.
>> Shogan: Grants served as a
quartermaster in the Mexican war,
do we see any signs of early
brilliance in him in this period?
>> White: He bristled against
being the quartermaster,
this for him his perspective
took him
out of active duty
sometimes broke through that
and did participate
especially in a daring episode
in the war of Mexico in Monterey.
I think he had the latent
qualities of leadership
and Gen. Zachary Taylor picked
him to be the quartermaster
because he saw Grant's ability to
organize, to think about the fact
that you have to supply an army
in a very difficult terrain
and this would come to the fore
later on, Grant didn't see it
at the time but he had to supply an
army in the Civil War often marching
where there're no supply lines,
especially in the battle
of Vicksburg.
>> Shogan: One of the popular
conceptions of Grant is
that he had a problem with
alcohol, that he was an alcoholic
and you do treat, you do
discuss this in the book
about how he departs the Army in
his first, the first departure
of the Army in the first
instance, but then in the remainder
of the book, that simply goes
away, there's not an emphasis
on Grant being an alcoholic or
having a problem with alcohol,
do you think that is a
popular misconception
of Grant, can you comment on that?
>> White: It is a popular
conception,
misconception I was struggling with
kind of many pieces of the puzzle
and one of the pieces
was Grant's drinking.
I think Grant didn't drink,
I don't think he was an
alcoholic or a drunkard.
When he was posted to the
Pacific coast away from Julia,
away even from the second child he
never seen, he fell into drinking,
I'm convinced he did,
but the story is mixed,
different people give
different reports.
Grant wanted Julia with him, when
Julia was with him he did not drink
and so I think as he moved
forward into his adult life,
the drinking fell by the
wayside, but drinking was a way
that his comrades in the
military would try to put it down,
this guy that his meteoric rise
they kept the story alive oh,
he's a drunkard.
>> Shogan: One of the most
surprising elements in the book,
when I was reading it, I
almost couldn't believe it,
I am almost dropped the book
was that for a brief moment
in time Grant was a slave owner, can
you tell us how that came to pass
and how he swerved this if all
with his abolitionist father.
>> White: The slave that he
owned William was given to him
by his father-in-law, he helped
him in his farming in Missouri
and if one is fortunate to visit the
U. S Grant national historic site,
the Park service site near
St. Louis, their film,
their new film begins with the story
of Grant manumitting the slave.
Grant characteristically never talks
about it, he was down in his luck,
had almost no money, this slave
could've brought him a thousand
dollars which was a lot of money in
those days, but he freed that slave
in 1859, he could not, I think bear
any longer to be a slave owner.
>> Shogan: When the civil war
breaks out, Grant is working
for his father's letter good store
in Illinois, why does she decide
to rejoin the military
on the side of the union?
>> White: Well, very
quickly he does decide that,
he's the only West
Point graduate in Galena
and the first letter he writes is
to his father-in-law Frederick Dent
and he tells him that
he must join this war
and that this war will
mean the end of slavery,
he then quickly writes a
second letter to his own father
and he says this war will decide who
are traitors and who are patriots.
I am a patriot and he steps
forward, there's no question
but the question will
becomes, where can he serve?
This becomes a more
difficult part of the story.
>> Shogan: How does Grant evolve
or change during the Civil War
and what characteristics or
characteristics do we see in Grant
that demonstrate why
he was so successful?
>> White: Grant had what I
would call latent qualities
of leadership not brought out
during his days at West Point,
not really brought out in
his first military postings,
they begin to come to the
surface when he leads people
across the Isthmus of Panama
when he's posted to the West
and his people are dropping in hours
from cholera he alone
steps forward the sort
of supervise not just military
men but women and children
across Isthmus of Panama.
I think if I were to give one word
to what it would be
the word determination,
Lincoln called it pugnacity,
when he finally assumes command
of all the Union forces and
enters into Virginia and is stuck
in this terrible place called the
wilderness Lincoln says to his aids,
if any other general had been in
this situation he would've been back
on the other side of the Rapidan,
back towards Washington DC,
it is Grant's pugnacity
that wins determination.
>> Shogan: Another special
relationship, I'm just following
up on this that you talked about
in the book is the relationship
between Lincoln and Grant, how
do you think and why do you think
that Lincoln was able to
recognize this tenacity in Grant
when others didn't see it?
>> White: Well Lincoln had
made a habit of visiting all
of his generals or actually having
them visit him, he couldn't do
that with Grant because
Grant was in the West,
but he saw from a distance
Grant's qualities
as a Western man not presumptuous,
not asking for too much,
not complaining, the funny
story is with Grant's drinking,
Lincoln the teetotaler
heard the Grant was drinking
and Lincoln says well let's find
out what he was drinking and give
that to all the other generals
and so they found a kind
of a relationship of
mutual admiration.
In fact Lincoln is kind of
funny here, he finally says
to Grant Ulysses, don't tell me
your plans I can't keep secrets,
I trust your plans, you carry
them out and I will support you.
>> Shogan: You do a very good job,
a terrific job in the book talking
about the military
campaigns that Grant engaged
in during the Civil War
and as someone like myself
who is not a military
historian very easy
to understand the campaigns
particularly the maps
that you enclosed in
include in the book,
we can't talk about all
the battles but I wonder
if you could tell us a story after
the Battle of the Wilderness.
So this is in May of 1864 and Grant
comes to a very momentous decions
across worlds even, and he
tells us about that and how
that affects the continued
prosecution of the civil war.
>> White: Well, remember
Grant had come from the west
to lead an Eastern Army
and the Eastern Army
was suspicious of Grant.
You've been successful in the West
but you've never faced Bobby Lee,
you've never faced Bobby Lee.
So Grant assumes command, the troops
are not quite sure whether he's
up to the task, he
enters into the wilderness
which is a scrub oak forest
about 4 or 5 feet tall
where suddenly he realizes that his
cavalry horses are of no effect,
artillery is of no effect,
they didn't use the term
but friendly fire begins to take
place, men lose their location
and begin to shoot at each other and
the force catches fire and men begin
to burn to death and they shoot
themselves before the fire
suffocates and kills them.
So after two days Grant had
suffered 18,000 casualties
and a general arrives in his
camp and says I know Robert E Lee
and he's going to do
this, that the other
and Grant was a very quiet man
suddenly raises up off his haunches
and said "I am tired of hearing
what Robert E Lee is going to do,
some of you seem to think is going
to turn a double somersault
and land on our camp."
So the next morning Grant says we're
going to march this next evening
but don't give the word out,
I've walked the wilderness
and Grant comes down this
remarkable road it's 8:30 at night,
he's riding this huge
horse Cincinnati
and that the troops are gathered
around, what is he going to do?
And he comes to a junction, he
will either turn north and retreat
for the fifth time of the Union
Army back towards Washington
or he'll turn south.
Fortunately we had an artist
there that evening with pencil
and he describes what
happens and Grant gets
to that junction still there
today and he turned south
and the men throw their hats and
begin to cheer, and they begin
to sing at the singing
Army, aren't we glad
to get out of the wilderness?
And that's the moment that
Grant had won the command
and the respect of this Union Army.
>> Shogan: It's a terrific story,
it's a very momentous point
in the book, very dramatic
and the way you,
I loved the way you tell it.
To fast forward into Grant's
political career often also
conceived I think in some
ways in a negative light,
you do talk about the
various scandals
in his presidential administration,
you don't shy away from that,
but you having a different treatment
of it because you included a chapter
about Grant's use on Indian
policy, you also have a chapter
on Grant's war against the Ku
Klux Klan and I wanted to know,
do you include those
chapters in the book to try
to give a more holistic view of
Grant's political career perhaps
to mitigate some of
the preconception
of his scandal ridden presidency?
>> White: Well, many
of the biographies
of Grant treat him much more as the
Civil War general in some ways pass
over the presidency, the scandals
all took place in the second term
and my conviction became that that
second term unfortunately began
to define both terms.
So let's look at both terms, in
his inaugural address in 1869
for the first time an American
president says we must address the
Indian question, we've treated the
Indians in this country immorally.
Grant did not campaign but he
went West all the way to Denver
and he came back with
a recognition, hey,
the real problem is not the
Indians, it's the settlers.
Now he's arrayed against
both Sheridan and Sherman,
against his own army colleagues and
he calls a meeting within two weeks
of the leaders of all the Christian
churches to say we must put
in place a new policy
for the American Indian
that treats him fairly.
I was much surprised by what
he did with the Ku Klux Klan.
He came kind of late really into
his own antislavery position
but as the Republican
Party was really retreated
from reconstruction, Grant stepped
forward to defend the rights
of the African-American, voter
suppression was alive then and now,
and the voter suppression then was
perpetrated by the Ku Klux Klan
in alliance with the
Democratic Party,
they wanted African-Americans
not to vote,
we think Barack Obama was
the first president elected
with a nonwhite majority, not so.
Grant won easily the electoral vote
but he only won the popular vote
because 400,000 African-Americans
voted for him and so the Klan wanted
to stop African-Americans in voting
because they knew they would vote
overwhelmingly for Republicans.
So one of the most exciting stories
is I think Grant was the last
president to stand up
for African-Americans
until John F. Kennedy
and Lyndon B. Johnson
and African-Americans knew
this and they rallied to him,
Frederick Douglass was a tremendous
campaigner for Ulysses S Grant,
he really believed in him.
>> Shogan: The last question
after I finished the book,
the book is terrifically as I said
before, terrifically well-written
and very well researched
and I finished the book,
I still felt as though Grant was
a little bit illusive for, to me,
I couldn't quite figure out
exactly what made him tick,
but I just read your book and
you spent years researching
and thinking about Grant.
So I wanted to ask you, is Grant
illusive still to you or do you feel
like you really understand him?
Well, first Colleen, my approach
to biography is what I call
from the inside out, I think often
we focus on politics and military
and we focus on what a person did
so I thought I knew about Grant
when I started the biography
he was obviously central
in my Lincoln biography and
after about a year I came
to my own conclusion I
don't really know the man,
I don't really know the man,
and then towards the end
of the book I came to this
conclusion Grant was an introvert,
there wasn't that terminology
in the 19th century
that Susan Kane wrote this great
book called Quiet in which he argues
that extroverts win in our society.
So Grant wasn't a good public
speaker, he was an extrovert
but he was a great writer, he
was also a very good listener.
Introverts are often better
listeners than extroverts are,
but it was hard to get
inside of an introvert
because he didn't fully reveal
himself, the reason the letters
to Julie are so important is he
reveals himself to her in a way
that he doesn't to anybody else.
So he is certainly elusive but
but he's also this remarkable
person who, if I had one phrase
to call upon, I would
call it the moral courage
of a man is what I think
commends him to a modern audience.
>> Shogan: Thank you, I know
you had wanted to read excerpts
from your book and I
think we have time to do
that before we take questions.
>> White: When you write a
prologue you think for a long time,
how would you begin a book, how
would you introduce readers?
People know about Abraham Lincoln
but most people do not know
very much about Ulysses S Grant.
"The man of middle height
accompanied by a young boy arrived
at the crowded Baltimore in Ohio
Railroad station in Washington
on the cold crisp morning,
it was March 8, 1864.
He hailed a carriage and
asked the driver to take them
to Willard's hotel at the northwest
corner of Pennsylvania Avenue
and 14th St. only two
blocks from the White House,
the man in voice stepped from
the carriage and walked directly
to the front desk,
the man 42 years old
and wearing a travel stain
duster asked for a room.
The clerk sniffed brusquely,
did not the visitor know
that in wartime Washington few
rooms are available especially
at Willard's the finest hotel
in the nation's capital?
The clerk dallied then informed the
travelers he could give them a small
room on the top floor, that would
be fine the man said softly.
The clerk asked the guests
to sign the hotel register,
when the clerk turned
the register around
and read the signature U.S Grant and
son Galena Illinois, he turned pale.
He gasped Gen. Grant, why
didn't you tell me who you were?
[Inaudible] more closely
the clerk could now see
that underneath the duster mostly
hidden was the blue uniform
of a union officer, Grant typically
almost always wore a private's
uniform, never a general's uniform.
The clerk is seeing
posters portraying the hero
of the West everywhere in Washington
suddenly attended he learned
out that he was reassigning Grant
and his son the parlor Suite
6, the best in the hotel.
Indeed the same suite Abraham
and Mary Lincoln had stayed
in three years earlier when
they arrived in Washington.
Now that he knew who was
standing in front of him,
the clerk handed Grant a sealed
envelope, the general opened
in finding an invitation to join
President Lincoln at a reception
that evening at the White
House as the guest of honor,
because he had not served in the
Eastern theater of the Civil War,
curiosity about Grant punctuated
conversations everywhere.
Many knew the outline of his rise
to fame but still they wondered
out loud, who was he,
how would he succeeded
when so many union generals had
failed over the past three years,
why have the president
elevated him to the position
of the lieutenant general?
The first man since George
Washington to hold that rank,
why had Lincoln tapped him to
come from the Western theater
to lead all the Union armies?
Humility and modesty are not en
vogue today, this is the story
of a the man, who is humble, who's
self-effacing, who didn't say
as modern celebrities would
say, don't you know who I am?
Grant would never have said that,
he simply accepted the room,
small room at the top
floor of the hotel,
I thought this was the
best way to introduce him."
>> Thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
So we have plenty of time for
questions from the audience,
we'll ultimately start over here.
>> Thank you.
Very interesting presentation.
I'd like you to comment on two
different aspects if you would
of the personality,
getting to know Grant.
Number one, if you could comment
which I believe is the order number
ten, alright where the first time
in American history where
US citizens who happened
to have been Jews worked, he banned
from the territories
under his control.
So that's one aspect.
The second, if you could comment
again, his personality, well,
post-presidency the man was
bankrupt in tremendous debt,
yet his moral obligation where,
he insisted in paying
back all his debt rather
than letting them slide
by, even to the extent
of selling his sword to do so.
>> White: Thank you
for both questions.
So order number 11, it's December
1862, Grant is very concerned
that the people in
Washington do not understand
that they are allowing
trading to take place
which is benefiting the Confederates
and many of the traders are Jewish.
So he offered, he promulgates
this order to stop Jewish traders,
Julio refer to this later
on "that awful order."
Lincoln will overturn it and
so there's a recent book called
when Grant expelled the Jews,
but what happens is I think the
key ingredient we should look
at as readers is, are
they willing and able
to admit their mistakes
and to learn from them?
And the Jewish author suggested
Lincoln did, that Grant did.
That he recognized the terrible
mistake he had made and that Grant,
when you continue the story
would appoint more Jews
to his administration
by far than anyone else,
that he became a great friend
of the Jewish community,
that he was present at by
invitation at the installation
of the first Jewish
synagogue in Washington,
that he recognized the mistake
he made and made amends for it,
he felt terrible at
what he had done.
He changed his whole attitude
toward the Jewish community
as a result of that.
Part of the story made him
really angry was his own father
who was always trying to benefit
from Grant's position had been hired
by a Jewish company in
Cincinnati and was there
in the South doing this
trading and he told his father
to stop this, what are you doing?
Second story is, Grant
at the end of his life,
there were no presidential
pensions, he had traveled the world,
he had made some money and
so he invested the money
in his son's Wall Street firm.
His son was a partner, the
other partner was involved
in a Ponzi scheme and on
a particular day in 1864,
Grant came to Wall Street to
learn that he lost every penny,
he went home he had $81 to his
name and this is why he will end
up writing his memoirs which he
didn't want to do because he had
to find a way to provide
for Julia after his death,
he was dying of cancer when he
started writing his memoirs.
>> You stressed the importance
of the formative years,
would you be able to compare
Grant's experience at West Point
versus Lee's experience
at West Point.
Grant is so clear that this is a
war of patriotism versus traitors,
Lee having a different
view and then the issue
that Mrs Grant I gather
invited Mrs Jefferson Davis
to give a dedication to his tomb.
>> White: Yes.
Thank you for the question.
Lee was the rock star at West Point,
the only West Point graduate never
to have a demerit, they were
of a different generation,
Lee graduated almost
20 years before Grant.
Grant didn't do so well at West
Point, he was 21st out of 39
and in his memoir, he
says I must apologize
and I thought, why did he apologize?
West Point was an engineering
school,
the language for military study was
French all the military literature
coming out of the Napoleonic
war was French
and then Grant says I spent
my time reading novels.
So I looked in the library
records of that time
and there were no novels, novels
were the sitcoms of that day
and as a strict Methodist that was
his Christian upbringing they would
have been scandalous or spirialist,
but I think great writers are
invariably great readers and I want
to find out, what did Grant read?
He tells us what he read
and that became a key
for me the Grant was a person
of intellectual curiosity
and imagination and
his reading was a key
to understanding to who he became.
>> If Grant was alive right now,
what do you think he would say?
>> Shogan: That's a good question.
>> White: Well, early on when
Grant as Colleen reminded us was
in Galena he went down
to Springfield to see
if he might find a position in the
Union Army and he wrote his father,
he said "I will never participate
in the kind of trading and ambition
that these military officers
are in, that's not who I am."
When he wrote to Sherman
after being elected president,
he said "I was forced into it,
in spite of myself we need more
humility, we need more modesty,
we need the ability to say I
was wrong, I made a mistake,
I'm willing to change" and that's
the vision for American leadership
that I think Grant helps us to see.
>> Being a career teacher with
especially history, you know,
we discuss American presidents often
and Grant practically is grouped
with the Warren G Harding,
unfortunately in terms
of our worst presidents,
like you said probably mostly
because of the second
term, my question is,
in terms of the reconstruction
policy during his two terms,
what kind of successes and failures
that he have, in terms of, you know,
if you can place in the context
of that whole reconstruction
period especially in terms
of of how he tried to help empower
the freed black men who were trying
to basically restore some
semblance of order in the South
after the Civil War of course
some the whites were not having
that but...
>> White: Yes thank you.
Well, Grant is actually rising,
I participated for the first time
in the C-SPAN 2017 presidential
survey, it was the third survey
of the 21st century and each of
these three surveys Grant is rising
as people recognize this, and
there's 10 different categories
by which you rank a president
and the highest category
for Grant is social justice.
He should have even as
higher as rank number 10
of all the American presidents
and that's because of his standing
for the rights of African-Americans.
So Grant comes into reconstruction
with a very deferential position
as a military officer, he's
subservient to political officers
but then he recognizes on
sadly under Andrew Johnson,
he can't take that position, he
can't cooperate with Johnson.
So he begins to be more
politically astute to participate
with Republicans in Congress,
to stand with them on the 13th,
14th and 15th amendments, but then
as they retreat, he won't retreat
and the Republicans were even saying
"well, let the South handle this,"
no, no, no he said, we
have to deal with this.
So I think that's one of
the finest moments of Grant
when he steps forward to defend
the rights of the freed man.
>> Thank you.
>> I'd like to ask you about Grants
changing military reputation,
really because of, of course after
1865 he is the hero of Appomattox,
the one who won the war and
it continues and sometime
around the start of the 20th
century, he becomes the butcher
and so on and now which I think it's
the correct interpretation is his
military reputation
seems to be recovering,
could you tell us why
there was the change,
I mean there's different
thoughts on that.
>> White: Yes.
Well, the downturn of his
reputation came about because
of what we call the lost cause,
this was the view propagated
by Confederate generals and
southern newspaper editors
that the best cause actually lost
and the only reason the South lost
was that they were overwhelmed
by a numerical superiority of the
Union Army, the industrial might
of the North, and that
butcher Grant who was willing
to just let his men
be killed compared
to the gallant Robert E Lee.
Well for 50 years we've
known that that's not true,
but it hasn't seeped into
the popular imagination
that Grant's casualties one by
one are actually less than Lee.
I've been informed by the fact
that since writing the
book I've become a friend
of Gen. David Petraeus,
in a week ago Tuesday he
and I together did a convocation
at West Point and Petraeus says
without question Grant is the
greatest American general.
On what basis?
He said you judge a general
by three categories, strategy;
the overall sense of
what you're doing.
Operation; you're combining
your leading in multiple armies,
and tactical a particular battle and
he said Grant is A+ on all three.
So Petraeus said to the
cadets at West Point,
I read Grant in preparing for the
surge in Iraq and I told my generals
in Iraq to read Grant, he is
the great American general,
the only general who is
an A in all three areas.
So this is been, from this,
I'm not a military expert
but this is fascinating,
Grant's reputation now has
really eclipsed Lee or any other,
Eisenhower, any other
American general.
>> I have a follow up on
the young reader's question,
so how do you think Grant would feel
about honoring confederate generals,
statues like the debate
we're having right now.
>> White: Good question.
Well, first of all Grant
defended Robert E Lee
when Andrew Johnson wanted to try
him for treason, he said you need
to realize first of all he is
not a traitor and secondly,
he is what Grant called the
spiritual leader of the South
and the way we treat Robert E
Lee will be the way he hoped Lee
would respond.
Now Grant didn't live to
see the monuments built
and the first monuments were
actually built in cemeteries
as the greatest generation
of that century was dying,
wives and especially daughters
wanted to put into the cemeteries,
the the men who had been
important that their sons
or fathers have served under them.
Only later 1890s, even the 20th
century were the monuments raised
in southern cities and these often
were, we want to tell you who's
in charge, this is white
supremacy, this is Jim Crow.
So there's two different things,
I think some of these deserve now
to be put into museums
and not on streets,
but this a very complicated
issue and we have
to remember the historical
reason that this came into being,
I wish we did have a
monument of Long Street
who was Grant's greatest friend
because he became a follower
of Grant and a Republican
advocate of reconstruction
and a scalawag, a bad
guy in the South.
I wish we did have monuments to
African-Americans who were leaders.
So we had very selective
use of monuments.
>> I heard a very disturbing story
about Grant's son at West Point,
that he was a leader of
the bullies against the one
or two African-Americans young men
there, and I just want to know,
how that jived with Grant as
the father of this young man
and how did his influence
in his family not seep
down to his children?
>> White: Yes, you're
telling a correct story
that Grant's son was involved,
his oldest son Frederick
in a bullying episode against
African-Americans and you're right
to ask how does this seep down,
because at the end of Grant's life
that he writes this note to
Julia, he's dying of cancer,
he will finish his memoir
three days before his death,
he can't speak this to Julia, he's
too emotional so his toxin is coded
and she will find it after his
death and he says to her, he said,
you know, "it wouldn't bother
me a bit if I discovered in any
of our children was lying on
a bed of pain in a near death,
what would bother me the most was if
they separated from the moral values
that you and I have
attempted to teach them."
So actually that later careers of
all the children are quite good
but that's an episode that
is right there is no way
of explaining it, yeah.
>> I was wondering if you had any
views about why there seems to be
so much interest in
Grant during our time,
I read Jean Edward Smith's biography
which I thought is wonderful
and then not long after I completed
it, I saw that you have written one
and I read your other
books about Lincoln
and I saw the wonderful reviews
of this book and so I had
to read your book as well and
not more than probably a few days
after I purchased your book, I
realized that Ron [inaudible]
and I just wondering what,
if you have the views
of why the biographies
of Grant during our time?
>> White: Well, David McCullough
has said well that, you know,
I think we want to
sort of recover people
who for various reasons have
been under the, under the radar,
so he did a wonderful job with
John Adams and Harry Truman
and so Grant seems to be one
of those figures that it's time
to recover perhaps the
celebration or commemoration
of the Civil War 2011, 15 that's
long after Jean Edward Smith's book
but that's also kind of put
Grant back in the spotlight.
The Grant in a strange interesting
story, the Grant papers which were
for many, many years of Southern
Illinois University are now
at Mississippi State University,
Grant has returned to Mississippi.
So and it's fascinating
the president
of Mississippi State is just
thrilled to have the Grant papers,
they are building a whole new
Florida library for this you know.
So there's a lot of things
that kind of converge in here,
that are kind of giving
a fresh impetus
to take a look at Grant again.
>> The question I was
going to ask you already,
answer with the other question.
So I'm just going to follow up
and say, when you have histories,
when you're writing a new
history about something
that has had many history books
written, are you grappling
with the history of his histories
and also when that stories changes
over time as you explained,
how do you see your role
and how do you grapple
with the history aside
from the popular notion of the time?
>> White: Good question.
We call this kind of, in the
history discipline Historiography
and so yes different figures
are viewed in different ways
in the climate of opinion
of that period
and there was a wonderful biography
that won the Pulitzer Prize
in the 1980s but it was written
in the era of the antiwar,
anti-Vietnam period, and so
that was not a time to lift up,
will we ever again elect a general
to be president of
the United States?
Our experiences of
Vietnam and now Afghanistan
and now Iraq have made us, made some
of us at least kind of jaundiced
or wondering about the military,
and so you have to be very aware
of the Historiography but again
I feel that in every generation,
there's an opportunity to
take a fresh look at figures.
So 20, 10, 20, 30 years and now
will be new books on Lincoln
as well there should be, and
our own questions perhaps
and our own political culture
may force us to see persons
in a different light than
maybe earlier generations did.
>> One comment.
At Gettysburg there's
a statue of Longstreet,
it's a very unique statue and he
looks like he's this huge guy riding
on a hobbit horse so I think
the South did it to him again.
My other question is after
all this is said and done,
why did Grant not have Meade at
[inaudible] courthouse with him?
>> White: Very good question.
When Grant came East to lead all
the Union armies, Gen. George Meade
who had won the victory at
Gettysburg was the commander
of the Army at Potomac and Meade who
was known as old snapping turtle,
he had quite a temper,
wrote a letter to his wife
in which he said I'm sure
that Grant would replace me,
I'm sure he will bring someone
from the West to be my replacement,
and he was so surprised
that Grant did not and many
of Grant's colleagues said
you got to replace this guy,
he doesn't do this, he
doesn't do that and Grant said
but he does do this and so
when Grant wanted Sherman
promoted one more time,
he wrote to the secretary of war
and said you will not promote
Sherman unless you promote Meade.
So Grant was very magnanimous
and very affirming
of his own commanders,
why Meade wasn't present
at Appomattox is a question
I'm not really able to answer,
I don't think I take it as
a negative because he went
out of his way to affirm
Meade so many times.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Hello, just regarding his
presidency, do you have anything
to say, I haven't your book
if you have anything to say
on his appointment of Anthony
Comstock as postmaster General
which I think probably is worst
thing he did, Comstock was sort
of a Newt Gingrich of the time
and then he would, yeah he boasted
that he resent 16 railway cars
a full of people to prison just
for having such things
which considered pornography
or condoms or anything like that.
So he like took over, he became
America's censor and did,
and Grant as far as know
did nothing about it and,
was there any blowback do
you know that he'd say,
what a mistake he made
or anything like that?
>> White: Well, Cabinet officers
were often as much nominated
by various constituencies as they
were chosen by the president.
So the constituencies might be
geographical or we need someone
from Pennsylvania or we need
someone from Massachusetts
or we should have someone
from Illinois.
If you want to accuse Grant one
of the most puzzling parts another
piece of the puzzle was if Grant was
such a good judge of character
in the military and he was,
why was he not such a good judge
of character in his cabinet?
And he often was not, in his
military he gave people the lead
to let them do what they wanted
to, Ambrose Burnside for example
who failed miserably twice,
when Ambrose Burnside came
to command the Army around
Knoxville, Grant went out of his way
to say to him and that he amazed
Burnside and he said, I trust you,
I believe you know
what you're doing,
you know more about this than I do.
So Grant gave great authority
to his core commanders.
He did so in many ways
to members of his cabinet
and unfortunately people
he shouldn't of trusted
and he should've micromanaged if it
were and so we have to fault them
at times for not understanding
fully,
he also had a deep DNA of loyalty.
So people who had been loyal to
him, he then became loyal to them
and he should've looked
more closely.
>> Thank you.
>> I wanted to ask you
about presidents we never hear
anything about, is Hayes, Harrison,
Pierce, Grover Cleveland.
Is it really possible that there no
great stories there or is it simply
that the publishing industry
won't publish books about people
who are perceived to be failures.
>> White: Both.
I'm sure there are great stories,
I mean Candace Millard wrote
this wonderful book on Destiny
of the Republic and the
story of James Garfield,
now she does this one little
way, she always does it
where she has alternating stories
about that, he's doing great things
and the physicians are killing him
by the way they're trying
to treat his wounds.
So Garfield if he had lived
probably would've become one
of our better presidents.
So I think that our
stories out there,
I mean there are various often
presidential present series
where people try to lift up these
ones, I'm not prepared to sort
of say, well of all these
this is the next one
but yeah I think we need the press
from time to time take fresh looks
at these people, yeah good comment.
>> Shogan: We have time
for one more question.
>> White: Okay.
>> Grant in both his army career
and also the presidency had
trouble dealing with people
who were horse trader types
political bend and economic bend,
can you talk a little bit
about how his inability to deal
with those individuals ranks
relative to his overall legacy.
>> White: Good question.
My tipping of the balance
I think is try to point
of the very positive things
that Grant that as president,
but I didn't want to
minimize what he didn't do,
I also think another factor in
this perhaps was that Grant did not
like confrontation maybe this
is another quality of introvert,
I'm not quite sure, and so he
didn't like to confront people
and he probably should've
confronted.
Now sometimes he did, I
mean William Rosecrans
who probably would've been voted
most likely to succeed in his class
at West Point why Grant
did confront him
and did let other people know
Rosecrans is not the person
that should be leading our
Army whether wherever he is,
but Grant should have been more of
a leader in this but that to me,
because when Grant retired
from the presidency in 1877,
he could've won a third term,
the scandals in his day did
not diminish his popularity,
he was incredibly popular, he
almost won another term in 1880,
he came very close to it when
he came back from his world tour
and if he had went to the convention
floor as Julia urged him to do,
he would have won the
nomination over James Garfield.
So I wanted to say,
how did the people
of his day assessed the scandals
and assessed his overall
popularity and achievement?
>> Shogan: Dr. White will be signing
books downstairs on the Expo floor,
please have a terrific afternoon
from the Library of Congress
at the national book
Festival and join me
in thanking Dr. Ronald White.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at LOC.gov